hello everybody
so you're just joining us which you
should because I just hit live button I
am doing a live unboxing of the new
MacBook Pro with the touch bar this is
the 15-inch I suspect this thing out -
basically it was like you know what I'm
going to get the best of the best
because this thing is going to be my new
child so if you guys are also not aware
the new MacBooks were announced I
believe it was a few weeks ago when I
lost track of time at this point but
this is the new one and they have the
new touch bar so it's basically going to
be integrated into different
applications and as you do things on
your computer the little touch bar will
change and it's going to be cool I'm
excited to try this out
so hopefully this this is actually
working I'm just gonna check here real
quick just to make sure because a live
video you never know you never know
what's gonna happen so let's just double
check see if we're live and if we are
I'm going to gonna open us up if you
guys want to tweet me I've also got
Twitter open
I've got everything happening let's see
I've got food being delivered uh but
most importantly is we're all here for
and we're here for the MacBook and it
looks like I'm live let's see if it's
working cool we're we're good we are
going to silence yourself go oh my gosh
so many things are happening so this is
a chat in the background and it's just
gonna roll okay guys here we go this is
my knife it's beautiful
everything is awesome let's be very
gentle
man I'm looking forward to this all day
that would be really really sad I cut
myself upon unboxing so I believe well
the initial reviews have been mixed a
lot of people are extremely upset with
the lack of ports on the pro model of a
MacBook I'm not gonna lie I'm definitely
a little bit upset but toward the form
factor and for it to be a little bit
slimmer things have to go but it's very
thoughtful that Apple did leave us with
a headphone jack so thank you you remove
the headphone jack on the iPhone and yet
you don't even give us a way to plug in
our new iPhone into your new Mac Pro
without using a dongle dongles for days
everybody ok we're gonna just we're just
shy just just open it probably I've
never done a lot of unboxing before this
feels very strange feels very very
strange but that's ok I'm just kidding
the or not could it what oh oh I'm so
nervous
it's the Space Gray oh you guys want to
see it here it is it's in its little
case it's little box it's little bed
this thing made all the way from China
in less than a day I feel like because I
checked the track you know I was like yo
guys my MacBook is gonna be here on
Monday and nobody believed me the best
part is my friends Jenna Madame Edie
photoshopped a fake shipping notice that
said that their MacBooks had shipped but
I had already fallen asleep and then
when I woke up I checked I was like oh
that's cool mind ship too so joke's on
you guys joke's on you
ah it doesn't even have a smell at all
this is very assuring peculiar usually
anytime elbow to a Macbook it's got a
smell that smells a little not good
we've got our instructions will there be
stickers if there's not a space gray
apple sticker in here I'm going to be so
upset I'm going to throw a fit throw a
tantrum ok I'm not but they're white
so that'll do now do pig that'll do pull
this back up just in case I need to
return it for some wild and crazy reason
that I'm like you know what I don't like
it it's the first thing that we have is
USBC charger which is now how you charge
the MacBook something that I already
don't like about this is look at this
this is a very stiff cable in comparison
to the smaller thin cable or the thicker
cable that you charged with it's just
like that's why I really didn't like the
MacBook Air a much bigger brick big much
bigger in comparison to the MacBook Air
not in comparison to the MacBook because
I believe it's probably the same as
exercise somebody told me that I think
it was a joke that there was someone
tweeted and said that inside of the box
if you cut this open that there is the
attachment that goes to this but I think
that they're lying because I don't feel
like there's anything else in here but I
wonder how many people are going to get
trolled and actually rip open their box
because I'm tempted to do so as well I
don't think there's anything else in
here and if there is
I've been fold I've been fold um
extender is under the plastic piece is
it really is it for real looking you
guys are telling me in the chat do I
should I rip it open and just see cuz if
that's actually under there I don't
believe it we're gonna just rip it open
and see we need we need a cruller right
or prove it wrong there's no way if
Apple actually put that underneath of
here that's just that would be
completely insanity but now I
okay I need to just test I got a test
because I need to prove this theory
wrong and I've got a knife okay I'm not
gonna cut over top of my brand new
MacBook so much for returning it guys
look there's no way there's no way that
they would ever do this
it smells good in there see you look
okay what hey guys I just needed to
return something I had a problem a
hundred percent that is not true there's
nothing under here there's nothing
inside of here
so don't be tricked now that I've
completely ruined that I'm going to
close this up before someone gets
severely hurt and since I'm the only one
here I'll be the one hurting myself all
right here's our USB C port or also
known as a Thunderbolt 3 I've been quite
conflicted trying to find a good USB C
or a Thunderbolt 3 travel hard drive I
did get the 2 terabyte version which is
very exciting
especially if you're giving a lot of
video editing or music production or
photos or video really anything that
involves a lot of space speaking of
space we have got the beautiful Space
Gray baby boy or a girl depending upon
what you want to what you want
mmm I'm upset that it wasn't in a snow
very upset here we go just make sure
this is a long shot opening it up whoa
it's turning on I didn't touch anything
yeah I'm ready for this action Oh hold
on I'm another one again one of the Gesu
din hold on wash your body okay let's
let's do a zoom can you guys see this is
it
there's the touch bar I'm gonna give it
I'm gonna give it a touch oh yeah
oops you can see I'm touching it feels
it feels real soft real slick I can't I
mean it essentially feels like the top
of an iPhone really mm yeah that's nice
okay let's bring you back out here okay
this is the joy of a livestream that
you're doing by yourself that's how we
roll here
someone's gonna fake it doesn't turn on
by itself it did I didn't touch anything
it turn you couldn't replay the tape
replay the tape guys I didn't touch
anything it just turned on
okay English of name language holy crap
I just touched the touchpad is huge it's
like I caressed the entire bottom of my
macbook the whole block this is a little
excessive this is a little excessive I
feel like I'm going to be like typing
and I'm going to be like all over my
laptop and it's going to be moving
around somebody just asked in the chat
does the back still light up no it
doesn't they have removed the light-up
Apple which is very sad it's okay
let's set this up we're gonna use
English as our main language
okay I'm in the United States
something's happening okay next continue
I've got six I'm going to type in my
Wi-Fi password it's a secret so what are
your guys initial thoughts please hold
my food is being delivered hello um yeah
you can just leave it at the door
yes
okay yeah you could just leave it there
that's fine or just use the code that's
in the app at the door
I'm not really sure what's happening I
know you can just leave it at the door
thank you thank you bye I kind of
starving but like I'm setting up my back
I had some very poor poor timing I'm
ordering food
okay I'm hitting next I'm signing in
some things are happening okay let's see
I'm just doing this because there's a
lot of things going on I've never set up
a live alive device before like this is
kind of terrifying I'm also a month of
the keyboard noise so they did redo the
keyboard from the previous MacBook Pros
so basically if you had used any of the
MacBook Airs it's that new butterfly
type effect it's kind of cool but it's
definitely something that you're going
to have to get used to that's in the
area on a second
it just feels it feels different it's a
lot easier to press down but they had to
do this to also help be able to make
this smaller then I can't even I can't
even tell you guys can you see how
freaking big this is it's a big it's a
big pad I agree to all of the terms that
you are telling me oh yeah passwords
this is this is the worst this is the
worst
why would I ever do this okay here we go
in the chat what's on the bar does the
keyboard light up the keyboard does
light up so you can see here this is for
the monitor this is for the isn't
lighting up or my blind did I just turn
it off so you can see it's lighten up
and yeah buddy we're gonna set this up
later thank you great can I get into my
computer now let's go you can have my
Diagnostics
we're not enabling Syria this actually
should've shoot okay
I'm enabling my touch ID I'm enabling my
touch ID let's zoom in for this lets
zoom in for this okay cool
all right that looks nice Oh God okay
touch it touch it
oops I pushed you hard touch touch touch
touch touch touch touch touch touch Oh
baby that's so good
that's so good Wow
okay let's move this back the greatest
livestream of them all okay um we're
gonna set up I pay later Apple pay
because the only thing that I wanted we
already have a line money Apple so why
do you want more of it come on what's up
see why does it sound like that some
people say they're disappointed the
people said who watches this I don't
know I'm not sure I mean if I was a Mac
fan I'd watch it if you were curious
about the touch bar I'd watch it since
Carly setting up my Mac it's pretty
light I'm going to grab my other laptop
and we can do a little size comparison
see the difference so here we've got
this is the previous version of the
MacBook it's definitely thinner they
essentially just completely ripped off
this whole top part of the MacBook so
it's now
I'm gonna really miss this I'm gonna
really miss this SD card slot a lot I'm
gonna miss a lot here it is I actually
haven't even used cierra yet this is
going to be the first time that I'm
using cierra I hadn't upgraded on any my
previous computers for fear the final
cut wasn't going to work and then final
cut ended up updating and then a lot of
things happen if you guys follow me on
twitter you probably know that the
tragedies that I had so we've got here
it is I don't really I guess I can have
something else this is Siri I guess I'll
enable Syria let's do it let's do it
Siri I was wondering what you think of
the new MacBook Pro
whoa okay did you see that did you see
that look at this turning up the volume
hey Siri hey Siri I was wondering if
maybe you could tell me your favorite
color my favorite color is well I don't
know how to say it in your language it's
sort of greenish but with more
dimensions
oh yeah mine too
all right hey Siri open keynote cool
we're gonna open up keynote and let's
see okay
create a presentation let's create a
fantastic presentation so if you see
here be a touch bar changed zoom to fit
skip slide hmm I like it I'm gonna start
downloading final cut because that's
probably one of the things that I'm
going to be using this the most in
here's what I'm thinking though when
you're typing or when I'm working I
guess I guess it's not that big of a
deal this is so big Oh like holy crap I
feel like this is a little bit excessive
they really went crazy on this thing it
looks good though this screen is super
crisp I do like how thinness is and that
it looks like it goes a little bit
further to the edge could just be see
the screen is so dirty hmm
it does feel lighter it's so so little
heavy a Wiley did even make this a
little bit shorter too which is kind of
nice
this is the 15 inch I got the 2 terabyte
of hard drive pretty excited uh I don't
have much more else to say I'm going to
do a follow-up video after this live
streams I'm going to go shoot that now
so I can get a little bit closer and a
little more in depth with a touch bar
because it's kind of hard to do live and
I feel like people are gonna probably
want to see a quicker video and see how
it all works but I think it looks good
and here's the unlock like the time I'm
excited about it I'm not excited about
the lack of ports because come on give
the people what they want you know
people half the time don't know what
they want so Apple tried to tell us and
most of the time I'm happy with it so I
will do a follow-up video and let you
guys know what I think and I'll see you
I'll see you later
that's it I'm gonna go stop the
livestream because I gotta stop and you
know what the irony of all of this is
I'm actually streaming on a PC right now
this is this is where the lives - magic
acids so we're gonna just stop